your systems are up in smoke or at least
it seems like that nothing is working
the CPU is a hundred percent and you
don't know why you can't get anything
done
well what's happened is you've been
dosed that's a denial of service attack
in a previous video I talked about the
CIA Triad in particular one of those
aspects was this business of
availability
a Dos attack or denial of service is an
attack on the availability of the system
let's drill into that in a little bit
more detail and find out what could be
well it turns out not all dos attacks
are the same most people tend to think
about one particular type which I will
talk about toward the end but in fact
there are different classes of denial of
service attacks so the first one I'm
going to talk about is sort of I'll
refer to it as a ninja attack it's a
surgical strike it's a Magic Bullet
whatever analogy you'd like to use but
it's a very targeted strike and in this
case what we do is we have a particular
system here that's operational and the
bad guy comes along and sends a
specially crafted message so he's taken
advantage of some rule that he's going
to violate in the protocol or he's using
a buffer overflow which is he's
allocating he's sending more information
than was expected in the particular
buffer where it was going to be received
in some way this packet has been
specially configured and specially
manufactured so that when it is sent to
the Target system the target system Goes
Up in Smoke it's one strike and the
system is down that's a type of denial
of service that not a lot of people
think about they generally think about
overwhelming with more volume and we'll
talk about that that's the next type
I'll refer to which is what I'll call
the death by a Thousand Cuts type of
attack in these attacks and there's a
number of different types that can
happen here but for instance if here is
our system
that's operational I'll give you an
example of an attack that dates back to
about 1996 which was one of the early
versions of this kind of attack
and it's called a synack or a sin flood
what happens is a bad guy wants to take
over this system so what he's going to
do is start by sending a packet what's
called a sin in TCP terminology this is
starting what is a three-way handshake
to begin a session he sends the sin
message
and what's supposed to happen in a
normal case is he puts in his address so
that the server responds with what's
known as a sin act a sin acknowledgment
but in fact what he does instead of
having it come back to him he sends the
sin acknowledgment to someplace else
he fakes out
an address and says don't send it to me
send it to someplace else so he's lying
about who he is
now in the meantime what happens is this
system starts a timer
and it allocates some resources for this
new session that it's starting and it
waits now on an acknowledgment to come
back from this place well this place
down here is unsuspecting it doesn't
know anything about this it just got a
random syn act message that it's going
to discard so it will never respond
in the meantime this system is holding
resources
the bad guy sends another sin and
another sin and another sin doesn't have
to send a ton of these but enough of
these where it's a death by a Thousand
Cuts no single one of these took the
system down but collectively each one of
them is reserving resources on this
system until finally it's out again this
was called a sin flood attack and we
have fixes for this now people have have
adjusted but the original TCP protocol
did not take into account that someone
might try to do something like this
there are other versions of this type of
attack things that do reflection things
that do amplification you can look up if
you're interested in something called a
Smurf attack which was of similar era
again we have ways to defend against
these things now but there are lessons
to be learned as we look forward so
these are two different types of Dos
attacks how about the third major type
of attack that a lot of people are
pretty familiar with and with this one
what we have is uh we start with uh this
is basically a death by a Thousand Cuts
times in where n is the number of users
that are involved in the attack and in
this case it's going to be unsuspecting
users so we start off with one regular
user who comes along and they would
access a system and everything's fine
in the meantime a bad guy over here
though is starting to take over systems
he has sent out some malware or he's
hacked into a bunch of systems and he's
building what is now effectively an army
of unsuspecting users that he's going to
later use in his attack we call this a
botnet or they were called zombies at
one point but these are basically
systems that are sitting here that the
user has no awareness that they have
latent code that could be exploited then
when the bad guy wants to start his
attack he sends a message out to all of
the systems in his bot Army and then
they all start bombarding this system
with traffic until it is way too much
for anyone to deal with this is what's
called a distributed denial of service
attack a DDOS attack it's distributed in
that unlike these the attack was in one
coming from one place in this case this
guy is just sending the command to start
the attack but the attack is really
emanating from a lot of different places
so that's why we call it a DDOS attack
and there are botnet armies that sit out
there right now today that can be used
by a bad guy all he has to do is wake
them up and send them on their task for
a particular Target
okay that's the scope of the problem and
there are many other types but that
gives you a general sense what can you
do about it well it turns out there's a
number of things so let's look at some
defenses here first of all the number
one defense for any sort of denial of
service attack and I'm going to say this
facetiously is infinite capacity
unfortunately nobody can afford that so
if you had infinitely capable systems
then you could throw as much as you
wanted to at them and they would be able
to withstand the attack but that's too
expensive what's the next best thing
redundancy
if you have only one system then one
system is a single point of failure if
you have multiple systems if for
instance in most cases we use what's
referred to as a rule of three where you
want to have at least three of
everything so if one goes down you're
not at fifty percent capacity you still
have what is a usable system so
redundancy is another important part to
have here adds to expense but it's
necessary pacing that is looking at the
traffic as it's coming in and limiting
how much we will accept over a specific
interval of time or traffic going out
which also comes to the point of
filtering now in some cases we want to
filter traffic coming in from certain
locations from certain IP addresses we
want to be able to turn these filters on
when we know we're under attack and we
and it's very difficult to do that in a
DDOS attack because the attack seems to
be coming from everywhere
we should also as responsible citizens
be looking at doing egress filtering or
filtering the data that's going out of
our systems for instance if the ISP for
this guy was looking and seeing that he
was sending lots of sins that were
referring to an address that's not him
they could have blocked that at the
source so the right kind of filtering as
the egress helps everyone if we do that
kind of thing other things you could do
would be Harden systems that means
remove unnecessary Services remove IDs
that are not needed remove capabilities
that are not going to be used every one
of those is something that a bad guy
could ultimately exploit later so we
don't want to have anything that's not
absolutely necessary on the system we
also want to change default passwords
and user IDs if at all possible patching
is another making sure that all the
systems have the latest software on them
it's software fixes that took care of a
lot of these earlier dos attack
scenarios so there there will the
vendors will continue to find ways to
fix their products and we need to keep
our capabilities up to that level of
where those fixes are monitoring being
able to look over the whole system and
understand when this is happening and
when it's not understand is our system
really under a load because we're being
Ultra successful right now maybe we just
put some new product on sale and
everybody's there or is it because a bad
guy has decided to try to take the
system down we need to be able to
understand the difference between the
two so monitoring and the Technologies
I've talked about in other videos the
the Sim security information event
management xdr extended detection and
response give us that kind of monitoring
capability and then finally it's
incident response or also called soar
security orchestration Automation and
response it's the ability to once we
realize we have a problem what are we
going to do we need Dynamic playbooks
that guide what our responses should be
so that we can respond quickly the
organizations that don't have that in
place are the ones that suffer the most
from denial of service attacks don't be
one of those victims